[Musique]
mec
puis [
Musique]
signe
[Musique]
s [
Musique]
ça s'appelle la prison centrale et l'
établissement de correction, donc le motif fondamental
et le but derrière l'existence de
cet établissement est de réformer et de
réhabiliter les détenus afin que nous  engagez-
les dans différents courants et l'art étant l'
une des meilleures avenues avec on
peut en fait sortir comme euh vous savez le
stress, la frustration, la colère et ainsi de suite euh les
engager dans des poursuites constructives les polit en quelque sorte,
cela les aide à
réfléchir sur leur passé, quel crime, quel
péché  ou quelle violation de la loi ils avaient
commise auparavant, donc ça
les affine en tant
qu'individu
[Musique]
ceci